my talk of the table is
controversy over something that matters
to all of us guess what it is Eminem's I
have a family you know anybody that
doesn't like Eminem a lot of them Eminem
says it's making the switch Nate you
didn't say you like him I love M M's oh
yeah okay making sure you're here
Eminem says it's making the switch after
getting some backlash can you imagine
getting backlash about some recent
changes to its spokes candies including
switching the Footwear on one of the one
of the one of the people adding a new
color people had some things to say
about that so the company says we just
want to give the candy a fresh take but
due to the negative feedback that
Eminem's that Eminem's received they're
now going to be on an indefinite break
who's going to take over as the
spokesperson I think they're in very
good hands funny lady Maya Rudolph love
her she'll make her debut as a
spokesperson in the Eminem Super Bowl ad
on Sunday which I like the Super Bowl
Nate yeah this is the Super Bowl it's
Sunday February 12th why does Nate know
because he's going to be there but this
is what Maya says as a lifelong love
cover of candy I feel it's such an honor
to be asked to be part of such a
legendary brand I mean you just don't
think of Eminem's as being controversial
and people would read all sorts of
things into the chain it was an M M plus
size why are they wearing sneakers
instead of tennis shoes I mean it got
that that crazy so they said look we're
going to take a break and we've asked
the lovely Maya to do it he'll kill it
people get very defensive about their
fictional characters it reminds me
actually when the Muppets had a
controversy over a sexual orientation of
the Muppets and I remember the they put
out a statement that said like they have
no sexual orientation yeah
exactly right exactly right